on assiste peut-être aujourd'hui à une
nouvelle forme de délinquance
technologiques les géants d'internet
sont victimes d'attaqués de pirates
informatiques sans foi ni loi
après le site américain yahoo la nuit
dernière deux autres sites ont été pris
d'assaut par un flux de connexion qui a
littéralement mis en déroute le système
l'explication sur ce phénomène qui ne
fait que s'amplifier avec patrice pollet
frédéric vion hier c'était yahoo l'un
des plus grands sites de recherche sur
internet qui était victime des hackers
les pirates informatiques pendant trois
heures yahoo a été bloqué impossible de
se connecter
cette nuit deux autres site amazon.com
et ebay ont subi le même sort
l'incident s'est produit vers 2 heures
heure de paris
décidément les pirates ne désarment pas
et voici comment il procède ce matin sur
yahoo
nous avons effectué une recherche à
partir du mot soumah on nous propose
l'arsenal de cherbourg en france avec
photos à l'appui
cette recherche n'a pris que quelques
secondes il ya ou peut traiter 1 620
millions de questions jouffre pour
bloquer yahoo c'est simple il suffit de
le submerger d'appel de saturer le
volume des demandes pour cela deux
solutions
première solution consiste à partie une
seule machine d'envoyer une sorte de
virus chez eux ou qui affirme une boucle
en fait
et à chaque fois que ça va essayer de
répondre la réponse d'un retourné au
serveur et ainsi de suite et on va
l'ossature de cette façon là une
deuxième façon deuxième méthode pour le
faire c'est que le pirate a commandé via
internet un certain nombre de pc une
grand un grand nombre de machines qu'ils
vont en fait attaqué simultanément deux
serveurs et ses machines ça peut être
les vôtres comme ça peut être en fait
des amis je pirate qu'il a à travers le
monde
et là c'est donc le nombre qui va subir
j'ai tout à fait aujourd'hui les hackers
attaques partout surtout ça fait mal
comme ici à la nsa l'agencé d'espionnage
électronique américaine en novembre
dernier pendant trois jours tous les
ordinateurs de ce centre de
renseignement étaient bloqués
la nsa n'a jamais précisé l'origine de
l'anomalie services secrets yahoo
amazon.com sur internet les pirates ont
de beaux jours devant eux
leur terrain de manoeuvre est sans
limite